[Music]
so thank you again for being here I'm
excited to talk to you today about kind
of the basics of our studio connected
internals and sort of what's going on
behind the scenes in the server and how
you can manage it and interact with it
so we're going to cover a few different
topics today so we'll start with just a
basic introduction to what is our studio
connect so if you're unfamiliar or that
you're new to this product and you know
cover that briefly secondly we will talk
about installation and setup and kind of
what you need to do and things that you
need to be aware of in order to
configure the product and then lastly
we'll dive a little bit deeper into a
few different areas on some details
about how the product works and some
some nuances that you should be aware of
as I mentioned we will be doing a
follow-on webinar to this one in a
couple of weeks and in that webinar I
will actually go into a lot more detail
on this third section or on more details
and some some more things that you
should be aware of if you want to manage
this product in a production environment
and then we'll conclude with a demo of
the product so that if you haven't seen
it yet you'll have an opportunity to
feel for what it does so our sugar
connects is an enterprise publishing and
management platform it can handle static
and dynamic content basically anything
that you can create with are including
documents presentations dashboards and
shiny applications and so one of the
nice things about this is that it has
push button publishing from the Art
Studio IDE and so if you're using a
recent version of the IDE you'll see
this little publish button that you see
here up at the top right you should be
able to click that and click publish to
our studio konnekt and if you register
an account on on our studio connect
server you'll be able to seamlessly
publish documents and our markdown
documents and it's shiny applications
and anything else that you're producing
in the IDE into connect it is an
on-premises enterprise product so this
is not an open source product but it is
something that you can install behind
your firewall and you know it's not a
hosted environments and lastly it
obviously is is meant for kind of
sharing data science artifacts within
your organization so this is a sneak
peek of kind of what most of your users
are going to see when they look at our
studio konnekt
so on the right here this is kind of the
full panel and you can see the majority
of the space is taken up on this lower
left here by the shiny application this
is what your users or you would be
creating to share within your
organization up at the top you can see
we have kind of a Settings toolbar and
some management there at the content and
then over on the right you've got your
settings panel which is where you can
manage in this case the performance of
the shiny application you can see
another screen shot separately on the
left here of what it looks like to
manage the access controls of different
content on the server as well so this is
one of the key features of Connect is
that you're going to be able to go in
publish directly from the IDE and now
you have this web interface to be able
to go in and navigate and manage your
content and set who should be able to
see it and who shouldn't so in order to
get started with actually do connect
your first just going to want to
download and install it so you can
download it from this link here or you
can find it on our website a similar
link that'll let you register and
download before you get started with
connect you will need to install our and
depending on which distribution here you
think you can either do that from your
package manager
most have are or if you're looking for a
particular version of our you can
compile it from source and then lastly
connect is made available as either a
Debian or an RPM installer file and so
the installation should be pretty
seamless you should just be able to on
any of the listed distributions here
Ubuntu 12 14 or 16 or red hat or CentOS
six and seven you should just be able to
run a commander two to be able to get
connected any dependencies that we have
up and running on your server so at that
point you should actually have connect
installed and it should be no more
difficult than that but one of the first
things that you're going to want to do
is go in and start configuring the
server and so you can see here an
example on the right of what a
configuration file looks like and so
these are just some of the basic
settings that you might be interested in
managing on the server and so up at the
top here you can see you've got your
sender emails it's the email address
from which you'll be sending any
outgoing email on the on the server will
be sent you've got your address which is
the URL where users should expect to
come back to your server and then you've
got basic settings here around you know
which port
do you want to be listening on if you
want to use SSL you can set up your
certificate and your key and then you
casa can figure out san